hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yandere simulator
now i asked you guys once you wanted me
to do in this next episode in the
popular request was that i kidnap
someone which I've done before but this
time torture them in my basement until
their mind breaks and they follow me
around school for senpai as a slave
doing whatever I wish them to do and
holy crap that seems dark but then again
a lot of what I do in this game is dark
and it's all for senpai let's go right
to school we don't have time to waste we
got work to do Oh God it is dark in this
school what happened here it's almost as
if someone got possessed by a demon then
that when around had murdered everybody
Oh God
ah that's better
don't know if everyone is still dead
which I would imagine they are nope
there's some it looks like everyone
seems to be spawning in is that senpai
oh my god senpai is that you you're so
handsome oh you're not at all like I
customized you to be Oh Jeremy are you
doing with your cross eyes you'll never
be as good as senpai Oh Mikael you if
you're swoopy hair I always liked you I
hate your [ __ ] family anyway we have
a lot of work to do yes so I gotta go to
the nurse
oh don't mind me it's just gonna steal
this oh it ain't nothing that you need
to worry about so I got the tranquilizer
now I just need to jab this into the
neck of an unsuspecting person while
they're in the area do I want to torture
Mackenzie you look great could you
follow me I need you to come with me
blues Mackenzie goddamn it I don't have
his enough reputation with her I need to
max out seduction and strength cool I
want to do that is my seduction inge
good Hey
are you seducing eyes never mind then
bye where's Boone Mackenzie my sedusa
nation skills are maxed but the boobs
McKenzie boobs oh no that's the nurse
boobs boobs boobs II bear there you are
hey can I get a favor can you follow me
I can tell people to go away good god
that's horrifying all right
hey Bugsy all right you're gonna come
with me you're gonna come over here
you're gonna come into the strange dark
closet with a weird mysterious object in
the middle of it come on
yeah come a-runnin I know it hurts when
you run but it's gonna be totally worth
it Hey there we go got that
well that's oh that didn't work I
thought that maybe that would be I seem
to have forgotten how to tranquilize
someone because I'm pretty sure I just
straight up murdered her somehow with
the syringe there was so much super
herpes and HIV on this syringe it just
killed her instantaneously oh damn that
super herpes la da da da da da oh [ __ ]
okay try this one more time and weird
blue hair guy no no no I don't know why
I was just I had boobs McKenzie in my
arms he should have loved both of us
more my problem was that I was not good
enough at the ability to do that thing
that I needed to do I need to be better
at skills I need to be nicer I need to
be happy and friendly and I need to go
to my class when I'm supposed to go to
my class this isn't my classroom is it
so I need to be better at biology ah
damn it's gonna take forever to get up
dammit we're going home I'm gonna sleep
think about math Empire why am I in my
90 night no video games is it all that
Yan Vania send fire the night I didn't
expect to be playing a game within a
game final stage heartbreak oh [ __ ]
I need to reset the week cool
alright there's much better and
hopefully my biology lessons are still
appropriate go to class your biology
[ __ ] forever because this particular
two days just to get enough to do the
thing
goodbye everybody you all suck in or
losers and you'll never get senpai away
from me
today is the day when I learned enough
biology to be able to tranquilize
someone [ __ ]
yes biology enough knowledge of medicine
and in the human body to administer a
tranquilizer the tranquilizers can only
be used on your current rival boozy
Pepsi you're not boobsie where's boobsie
you're not boobie either oh god I mean I
love you I mean I love you what are they
doing why are they taking such a long
lackadaisical path around the courtyard
what are you doing oh my god they're all
terminators oh stop it
well you're so weird I senpai you're not
weird you can never be weird oh my god
that's amazing you went right through
the door I love you okay now we gotta we
gotta wait till tomorrow at the booth
[ __ ] today's the day and I'm gonna make
my classmates stand right by don't mind
me I'm just standing here in the exact
same spot creepily for hours on end
Hey hello follow me I've got something
cool let's just not go bye senpai
because I don't want to be distracted by
you in any way come after me try to
chase me boobs ewwww
let me just make sure that I didn't miss
any steps here let me just close this
door here hey where's the syringe god
damn it I'll be right back don't go
nowhere nowhere
don't mind me ma'am we're all good
you're so stupid that you got stuck here
hey come here follow me yeah follow me
wall in here good very good
you're so good at doing that and now
oopsy poopsy flip there we go no blood
no blood no blood come with me oh oh so
delicate and delightful yes
now let me laugh out my insanity so no
one realizes
[Laughter]
okay why don't I not have my outfit
there we go that's traditional senpai
hunting outfit so I just need to go to
class perfectly normal wearing my
underwear on my head oh yeah now I
should be okay
yawn dairy Shan waits until midnight and
I got the case and we're good we're good
we don't have a lot of time left but I
think we're okay yeah maybe I don't know
let's go visit someone in our basement
[Music]
and I don't like that very much
how are you doing oh you don't look so
bad you look moderately pissed off okay
repeat after me I love senpai yes I do
he's for me not for you gonna cut his
balls off where am i my head then we'll
be together forever that didn't rhyme
but I don't care I love senpai yes I do
for me not for you not for you not for
you it's for me not for you okay anyway
now for the next 18 hours we're gonna
repeat the same mantra
I love senpai yes I do hate for me not
for you boy it's Friday
no one's gonna confess love to him today
I'm pretty sure it's this girl that does
that hello hi that's going put you for
one hour one hour one hour all right we
only got one hour of this I love senpai
yes I do hate for me not for you every
kind is balls off where I'm on my head
then we'll be together forever yeah
that's well when all my [ __ ] song
went I guess everything's gonna be okay
I need more time to be able to brainwash
her I don't know if I'm going to be able
to do that but I got a new rank up in
language that's good yes but what
heartbroken well that's a lot of
[ __ ] easy-peasy there'd be no way to
do this if I wasn't cheating but
cheating is just another word for
markiplier anyway yay doo doo doo dee
what a lovely day it is can't wait to go
back she got exactly no sleep at all
just constant on lube that me not gonna
get any sleep either it's constantly
none of that oh it's perfect
alright you ready for another 18 hours
of this i love senpai yes I do he's for
me um no I love senpai yes I do he's for
me and not for you it's time to lose all
of your sanity
I think she's broken now then how that
works
oh geez oh geez look at her you bring
your prisoner to school and put a weapon
in her hand she will kill your curd
and then kill herself oh my god all
right sure
come on boobs McKenzie you and I always
had a spit oh man oh wow Oh God just to
make it as brutal as possible I'm gonna
go get the the handsaw oh my god
horrifying well might as well go all out
on this one
so the thin pie and I can be together
forever
[Music]
I'll just stalk in the shadows I'm just
guarding my circular saw then pi will
understand these antics I just did this
for our love
he would understand OOP Z come on babe
oh can she not take the circular saw
okay oh come on oh don't be like that
Oh Oh it just wasn't the right oh okay
they needed like a smaller weapon Oh
good old-fashioned knife he knew all
right do it do it do it screw it
you blew it yeah I knew it
okay
[Music]
boobs McKenzie is the current rival
who's and Kenzie doesn't have a target
senpai
oh god I love you oh I love you I love
you nothing
this is how much I love you so there's
nothing that had a recent [ __ ] I got to
do it all over the laughing is perfectly
normal
ah privacy finally all right cool
come with me you cool individual who
dared look at senpai
you have a nice button there I know you
haven't heard this but I'm used to this
this is how I do things down here so
just repeat after me
well you don't repeat after me I'm gonna
say you say nothing what you mean
I love senpai yes I do anyway she passed
up I don't even know what your name is
so for now I'm just gonna call you
slagathor I in fairness to everybody
else so slagathor I'm only gonna go over
this a little more then you better
follow with me now
I love senpai yes I do you do not that's
very clear you do not you do not love
your bike okay now arrives is that good
is everybody clear on the subject good
morning how are you doing
I love the glassy look in your eyes come
on you're ready for school we've got a
big day in store so why not take the
screwdriver and do something with it do
it oh it's senpai senpai don't look oh
oh God I don't want you to see this
senpai you just go on inside and don't
worry about a thing
[Music]
oh really funny she's watching like a
hawk
nothing no one's gonna escape these
eagle eyes Hey yeah weird thing that
happened right teach man who'da thunk
huh that senpai guy what are your
feelings about him his name out of those
name his name senpai and that's all the
matters you don't know senpai good then
you get to last deep your head on a
swivel teeth hades do you know who did
this oh no I got no idea hey teach am I
to blame what no
never teach do you love senpai no no oh
God
what the [ __ ] was that the police
discovered the corpses of khokana Haruka
and Yui REO police discover a
screwdriver that is stained with the
blood of Yui Rio and kikuna Haruka find
the fingerprints of Rui Rui REO police
cannot perform an arrest question yonder
each an but cannot link her to any
crimes
why did you question me ah yeah now
there he stalks senpai until he's
returned home safe returns to her own
home okay so that was horrifying
Oh Oh a wonderful use of my time but at
least senpai is safe for another day so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what horrifying event I
should do in the next episode of yandere
simulator there's still even more stuff
to be done so thanks again everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]
this is how he died